Yes, this is going to
be kind of an intro
to shiny with some
R Markdown Markdown
and stuff mixed in there.
But first, we
already heard a bit
about how I introduce myself.
I'm Mike Garcia.
I'm a data scientist
with procol.
You know, you've heard
where and data science
company, everything
from talking about,
you know, advisory, regulatory
compliance, the planning
aspect to data
engineering and then
through to reporting doing
the data science and analytics
that then informs
the entire process.
And I think that is a loop that
goes back kind of where I fall
is more on these last two
doing it visualizations,
running models,
figuring out how to use
the data to answer a particular
business or science question.
And that's going
to be kind of the.
Focus of the workshop
today is using particularly
shinee for that visualization
and turning your archerd
into something interactive that
your end user can engage with.
So some quick, quick overview
and some explications workshop
goal is to
understand, first off,
what shinee is, the
basics of how you
structure a shiny application.
And then how to
make your own shiny.
And if we have time,
we're going to show
and we'll show you how
to incorporate chinee
into some dashboards with
the flex dashboard package.
Assumptions, not a lot
on the our background,
just some general
familiarity will be helpful.
What function is how to load it?
Call it data sets and packages.
Absolutely no prior
experience and shiny
or any kind of web
technologies is assumed at all.
We're going to use
Chinese heavily visual.
So we're going to use
plot for visualization.
If you haven't used it before.
That's fine.
But some and I'll cover
a little bit of this
in kind of our first warm
up module, of course,
if you can to use
base are for plotting.
You can absolutely incorporate
bizarre plots into shiny.
Kind of our general
structure that try to hold to
is this quick intro a quick
warm up the kind of shows
and you refresh on joujou
plot, if that's new to you.
We kind of build up
a shiny app in layers
that we're going to go to a
fancier app with some more
complex features.
And then we'll do a demo at
the end with the flex dashboard
package.
So first off, what is
shiny by definition
is a framework that allows R
users to create interactive web
apps without knowing
anything about web design.
So you don't really have to
think about all the underlying
web technologies you just use.
And it's kind of similar
to learning a new package.
They're a little bit.
You don't really need
to know basis webdesign,
but just a few basic
things is helpful.
So here's the one slide that
I'm going to talk about.
Web design, as I said,
abstracts away the underlying
technologies of the web design.
Which are three of them?
There's TML, which I'm
sure sounds probably
sounds pretty familiar if you
haven't worked with it before.
It's essentially the
building block of a web page
and your web browser
interprets it
and shows you the nice
reformatted websites that
were all used to their success
or cascading style sheets.
And this separates the content.
It's in what your app is
doing or what your website
is doing with how it looks.
So you can control
those independently,
you can change the content,
or you can update the theme.
But they're not tied together.
They're independent.
And then finally,
there's Javascript,
which is scripting language
that enables the interactivity
within a web page or a web app.
And typically, this is
executed in the user's browser
rather than on any
central server.
And the idea with shinee is
that it takes all of this
and wraps it up into an easy
to use interface and framework.
So for the workshop
today, we're going
to be using RStudio
cloud, you should
have received an
invite to the workspace
and been able to open
up your own session.
That's essentially a
clone or derivative
of this project here.
If you haven't put a question
into the chat and one
of our TAs can, I can
help you sort that out.
And just as a note to
throughout the entire workshop,
if you have questions
popping into the chat
either to get back
to you, I'll try
to pop in and monitor
it from time to time
to see if there are
things that would
be good to talk about
overall and keep this
as interactive as possible.
So first thing we're going to
do is start with the warm up,
actually, I'm going to
check in really quick just
to make sure that people are
generally able to access this.
If you're having problems
accessing any of this material,
if you could throw
that in the chat now,
just so I don't continue on if.
If most people are not able
to follow along the estimates,
I'm not sure if we
can see the chat.
So it's a little
tricky, but I do
have a link to share to the
actual RStudio Cloud space.
We did invite most of the
people that registered ahead
of the workshop today.
So you should have got
an email that gives you
a link to the project.
But if you didn't see that,
we have a general link that
is open, that should take
you directly into the space.
And I can drop a link to that
in the chat for everyone to see.
Let me just pull that up.
And I will put that in the chat.
OK, just give me two seconds.
I think most people
were able to I
saw that there were over
hundreds people had created
their own project for this.
So I think we should
be good to go.
I just wanted to clarify first.
All right, so start out in this.
So from the main folder, click
on the warm up, the warm up.
Are formed.
So R&amp;D is an R
Markdown document.
We'll go into a lot of the
details of our markdown,
specifically is.
But it's essentially a
way to integrate your code
with text and illiterate
programming paradigm.
And then there's a
lot of other features
that will add in
for interactivity
with either visualizations
and ultimately shiny.
We can kind of go
through this in just
like a notebook sort of format
and a few lines at a time.
Loads of packages.
This is the flex
dashboard package that
would actually use this open.
FDA is just a package that
interfaces with the open FDA
API to get some data.
You don't really need to know
the specifics about that,
but fun to play around with
if you haven't seen it before.
And then just some tiny packages
for manipulation and plotting
and energy, things
like package as well.
So let's start out with just
this is a helper function
to gather some data
from that open FDA API,
so we're going to grab a
function of gender brand name.
So this will be the
drug, brand name and age.
And yeah, this goes
through and submits a query
to some filtering on those
variables, brand, gender
and age, so that we
want it to account
for a limited to the top 10.
And then we're going
to submit the query
and then this just
does some formatting
for to give the age that
we want or to put age
in the correct format.
So now let's actually
get to doing something,
we're going to start
with stroke katriona,
and I think there
might be better ways
to do this, Pravda
reports, et cetera.
And that's exactly right.
We're going to build up to that.
So right now, we're just going
to say we're going to hard code
and say, we're
looking at you, truta,
and we're going to look
specifically at 20 to 65.
You see that create
function just creates it,
puts it in the format that
is required by the API.
They're going to run that
get adverse function.
Going to combine the data, some
are buying, stacking the data,
so it's rawboned.
And we want to take a quick
look at what that looks like.
If you.
And here we have a term.
Column These are adverse
events, the number
to account and the gender.
So we've got some
data, let's move ahead
and start plotting that, so.
You're going to cover
just you're not really
going to focus on teaching
tidy versus teaching Judy plot,
but I'm just going to go
over a few kind of key things
to either refresh your memory
or if you're new to this,
the key things to follow along.
So you see, we start
with a data set.
And we're going to read.
You can read this code just one
line at a time, thinking of it
as starting with the data set.
And then we're doing gooby
and then we're summarizing,
et cetera this operator
here is the pipe.
So it'll link things together,
starting with the data set.
And then we're going to apply
this next function to address
and we're going topoisomerase
to the summarize
the results of
these two together.
And so on.
Because they were
grouping by term,
which is that adverse event,
and we're going to summarize,
when you get the total
count with an adverse event
and we're going to move
on and start building up
the layers of our plot.
So the grammar of graphics,
it's this layered kind
of philosophy to how to
build up a visualization.
So it start out with just
kind of empty object.
And we're going to
add in a bar chart.
We're going to tell
it that we want.
We're doing something
a little fancier
to make the ordering
how we want it.
But we're going to tell it to
put this on the x axis, count
on the y-axis.
We're going to
put the coordinate
the coordinates around.
So instead of
vertical bars, it's
going to be horizontal
and get some labels,
apply a minimal theme.
And we just keep adding
these on top of each other.
So we can do all of
this in one pipeline.
And we get orographic.
Cool, so but that's just static.
We're going to learn how to make
this interactive and visual.
OK, so maybe take this one step
further and do it by gender.
So this is pretty
much the same code,
but we've added
one new line here.
And that's the fast wrap.
So instead of repeating copy
and pasting all this over again.
And doing it again,
filtering the male
and then just filtering female.
We can at the facet
wrap, and we're also
telling it to fill the bars
or do a color vijender,
so we've got you female on the
left here, male on the right.
And showing the distribution
of adverse events.
So that's pretty much what
you really need to know about.
Just think of it as
you're building up
all of these layers,
we're going to have
different plots using different
genomes for different graphics.
You do things, but
you won't really
need to write any of
that code yourself
if you don't if
you're new to plot
and are kind of learning
that alongside shiny.
Of course, this whole thing
is are more documents,
I've kind of got through it as
a notebook, but you know it.
And you can see it as an HTML.
All right, so.
Now that we're warmed
up, let's go in
and actually talk about
shinee, that's what we said,
we were going to talk about.
So let's dive in.
This first.
I've got a series
of templates here
and they just progressively
build up to a working shinee.
And so this first one is
absolute minimal, minimal
shinee app that you can have.
And it has four components of.
First off, you have to call
the library, of course,
shiny library shiny, you have
this fluid page function,
which is empty.
There's no arguments in it yet.
And we're assigning the output
of that function to this
you and you're giving it
the name UI and similar.
We've got this server, which is
a function that we're defining,
and it takes three inputs,
input output, session,
the names of the
arguments, and then
it's currently just
an empty function.
And then finally, we're
calling this shiny app
on the UI in the server.
So this is a fully
working China,
but it's a really boring.
And the one thing
you can do here,
if you click on Next to run
out, if you run in a window,
it will pop up a new
window for an external,
it'll pop up in
a browser window,
can also select viewer pain.
I'm going to do that
just for presentation is.
The environment, and now it'll
show up in this viewer pain
here.
So I can run that.
And it doesn't says says
it's listening on this.
Localhost on this
port, and it's busy,
it's doing something look
over the viewers, just empty
or simply because we haven't
actually done anything yet.
Let's go ahead and stop that.
So let's talk a little
bit about just the purpose
of these different components.
And then we'll actually
start putting some content
to solidify what those these
different things are doing.
So the UI is where we're going
to put everything related to.
What you might think of as
like the design and the look
and feel of the app.
So different buttons
and sliders and ways
of input, kind of
the overall layout,
the structure of the app
is going to go right there.
The server is where most of
your code is going to go.
That's going to
be the code that's
generating the plots that
may be filtering, according
to some dropdown venue.
That selected and
shiny app is actually
what's running the app.
So if you don't have
that last line this year,
your app will run.
A quick note to a helpful tip
that it's often useful when
you're either building
a complex app to build
like a little component
of it by itself,
or maybe you're going
through some exercise
and you get really tired
of copying boilerplate
over and over again.
Our RStudio has something called
a snippet that's built in.
If you just type in shiny
and you'll see this shiny app
snippet that pops up that'll
actually just populate your.
Code your menu with
that boilerplate,
so that's a quick
way, if you just
want to test it with
a particular input
or something does.
So we'll stop that app
and open up the next one.
So this one, we're
not we haven't changed
anything in the lower bid.
So we still have empty
server and the Shiny app.
What we've modified.
Now is we've added
something to the UI.
So this is kind of where we
start to think about what do we
want the app to look
like when you're actually
doing this in practice or
something more complicated?
It's often helpful to sit
down with a pen and paper
and actually sketch out what
you want it to look like.
Which components, which
visualizations do you want?
In which areas then?
It can get a little overwhelming
if you try to start building
after a little
complex, if you don't
have a good vision of what
you want it to look like.
So we've got something
like a title,
this thing called
sidebar layout panels,
let's just run this and
see what it looks like.
So we've got some
material here, we've
got our title going up here.
It's kind of interesting.
You might see the
sidebar layout that we've
specified, the position
left, although it's
kind of in the center.
And we've got it within
that sidebar layout.
See, that function comprises
like lines 8 through 16.
We've got two panels within
one for the inputs and one
for the main results, but
they're all kind of stacked
on top of each other.
So I'm going to give you a
moment or two to play around
with this, I've got a couple
exercises at the bottom.
Yeah, moving to try moving
the sidebar to the right,
maybe play around.
Is the order of this just kind
of play around for a minute
or so.
And get a feel.
For this, and if
you're kind of curious,
is, if anyone has any
ideas of why this might be.
Just act and not where it's not
actually putting on the left.
And are we actually
able to see the.
The chat, the questions,
unfortunately not.
I don't think for some reason,
it's based on operating system.
So far, though, I've seen
questions for getting the link.
Let's see.
Let me look in and see if
there's any other questions
in here that we can do that.
You might be able to answer
besides getting the link.
And we've got one
question saying,
are you going to be covering
shiny modules in today's
presentation?
Good question.
Unfortunately, I don't
think there's enough to go.
Time to go from absolute
intro to shiny all the way
to shiny modules in
the 90 minute workshop.
I wish I could say if
anyone cares about what that
is, it's just a way of kind of
breaking up your codes here,
getting less repetitive.
You might have like a
particular interface that
would drop down,
drop down menu that
creates this visualization.
And you want incorporate that
into their different parts
of your app or different
apps, entirely different kind
of modularize your
code and a fira.
You've written a lot of code,
you probably used to do that.
You write a function
to do something
rather than copying and pasting
the same thing over again.
So there's training
modules help address that,
but we don't have time to
get to that, unfortunately.
Awesome, Thank you, Mike.
I am I'm seeing if there's
any other questions.
And are you going to be covering
interactive plots in Shiny
today?
Yes, that will
definitely impact will.
We're on part two out of
five here, and by the time
we get to five, we will have
a basic interactive blog.
Excellent, perfect.
And so those are
all the questions
that I can see
coming in right now.
So if you want to keep on going.
And at any point if
you'd like to pause
and I can read out
some questions as well.
Sounds great.
Yeah, so, you know, it just
kind of go through this
and say, let's move
this to the right.
And see what happens.
Unsurprisingly, it looks the
same as if it was on the left,
and it was Senator
wise the right.
Now, maybe you're opening
this in a different window
or a browser and you
may have seen something
entirely differently.
The reason for this is
that the shiny recognizes
what size screen,
you're looking at this
looking at just this kind of
right portion of my screen.
And it is doing that
because it's small.
It's kind of viewing that
almost like a mobile device
or a tablet.
And if it placed
it on the left, it
would get everything
would be really scrunched
except for this,
especially when you
have a visualization in there.
But if I drag this
out far enough.
OK, now it's at some
point here, it decides,
OK, that's a big
enough screen and it
lets me do what I want to do.
But instead of having to
specify a different interface
for a mobile device
and a tablet and it
maybe a small like Surface
Pro and then a huge desktop,
it just it gets
smaller and it says,
OK, you probably actually don't
want your full interface here.
I'm just going to stack.
And because that's
going to look better.
But you can see now that's
on the right, if you.
It's on the left.
You can hit reload,
the apsey don't
have to actually
stop and reload,
but now our inputs
are on the left.
Cool so that's all the.
Interface, we haven't
really done anything
to make it interactive
at all yet,
it's still just a static
document, essentially.
So let's build this up a little
bit, let's we still have this,
you can see now it's getting
more complicated with this
is still a pretty simple app.
And this is why it's a good
idea to sketch things out
in advance rather than just
starting to put things in
and having it snowball
on you to end up
with a lot of spaghetti code.
So we still got our title,
still got our sidebar layout,
and now instead
of you know, we've
got our panel sidebar
panel and a main panel,
and within those
cities, you used to just
have some a little bit of text.
Now we've got a new kind
of suite of functions.
And these input functions.
And one of the keys to
understanding shinee, these
are the things
that make these are
the input side of the
reactive aspect of shinee.
So we've got two inputs
that we're putting in,
and you'll see a lot of
different sorts of input,
radio buttons, dropdown
sliders, and they
have like some sort of
descriptor and then input
and all of them
start with an ID.
This ID is key.
This is how you're going to
how the rest of your code,
when we start actually
writing the server side code,
is going to recognize
these different inputs.
And we give it a
label, which is.
Know human friendly,
make sure you know.
So we can read it.
And then there's different,
different, different arguments
depending on the books.
And this particular
one, we're looking at.
And this is a dropdown
and we're giving it.
These choices, we say you
can choose either seventy,
75% of the five or 90 here.
We've got a slighter input.
So you'll see those first two
arguments or the same effect.
A lot of times you want to
see people specify the name
to say slider input beans
come in number of bins.
But now since we
have a slider, we
need to give it a range
of the minimum value.
It can take the maximum value we
can take and the default value.
So that's all in the sidebar.
And in the main panel,
we're still not up
to full interactivity where
we have where, you know,
you're changing
inputs and you're
getting a visualization
that's changing.
But we're showing you
a couple of things
that you can embed
a local image.
If you want to put something
in or you can be both.
If you do know a
little HTML, you
might realize, OK,
that's the b.r. tag.
That's just an easy
way to put that in.
Right into your butt,
inject some basic HTML right
into your app.
So stop her previously
running one.
And it run out.
And so it's getting a little
bit more like something we want,
we've got at least what
feels like interactive,
but we can interact with it, you
know, pick different numbers,
move or slider around.
We actually have something
to look at over here.
But it's still there's
nothing there's
no logic in the back end.
There's no, we're not
running a visualization.
We're not generating a table.
And we're definitely
not connecting
anything that we're doing here
to our code that's running
to put results over here.
So finally, let's get on
to talking about the server
and switching it up a little
bit here and introducing
some data to play around with,
this is his data package.
And this is just cholerae
data from the London cholera
epidemic of the 19th century.
John Snow.
And we're moving things,
changing things a little bit
here to accommodate that
data, but not really, we still
have our slighter input.
And we have changed the
range a little bit there.
But now we've got something
a little bit different
in the main panel.
Before we had we were
just loading RStudio logo
and a little bit of text.
Now and say, like we
had the inputs up here.
Now we've got outputs.
So anything you can think
about your whole app
is the user specify
input and the app
taking that input and
returning is showing
a specific combination of
visualizations and tables
and a set of output
corresponding to that input.
This is where all
of your outputs go.
All of your outputs get wrapped
in these output functions.
So there's output, there's
one of corresponding ones,
four tables per text.
If you want to dynamically
render our markdown,
there's an output for that.
And similar to you,
you have this input ID
for each of your inputs, all
of your output identifications
have an outputted.
Now, hopefully you're
starting to see
that you've got all of these
different identifications
and components.
And really, if you had
that sketch laid out,
you can label them with this
is the idea for that, for that.
And just makes things
a lot cleaner to you
as you're building this
up if you have that.
At a map in your rough
sketch it out ahead of time.
And finally, we have
some server logic
that this was empty until now.
And emphasize it most,
this is mostly just.
Our code.
So we're going to ignore
most of it for the moment
or ignore these render plots
and stuff for the moment.
And it's.
I reckon that was my dad.
That was my dad.
No, no worries, reconnected
and didn't lose anything great.
Yes, so this is all just
our code right here.
So you call of duty plot,
give me the data set,
we're giving it the
value, telling it to you.
So we're trying to do
a histogram down here.
We're making box plots.
And that's great, and
what we're doing here
is now we're starting
to use those labels,
we're saying that we're
creating this plot,
but we're going to put
it in this histogram.
We're going to put
that in this output.
So we've kind of create a
space in our user interface
for the histogram.
And we're going to say, OK,
we're going to put this there.
And we wrap it in
this renderPlot
so that ultimately,
when our inputs change,
this listens to those inputs
and we'll update it only when.
So it's only when
the inputs change
that's not continually redoing.
If you change one
component, it's
not redoing your entire app.
It's just loading
the part that's
computing the part that
needs to be computed.
Similarly for the box by.
So let's run this, see
what it looks like.
And we have.
Something that actually looks
like a useful shiny out,
we've got our slider,
we've got two plots here.
But there's one thing
missing, and you
see if we're changing
the number of Ben's idea,
obviously, we want the number
of beds in our histogram
to change.
And it's not doing that.
And the reason why it's
not doing that is I'm
just telling it to take
the entire data set
to get a histogram.
Throw it in here,
there's nothing
tying it back to the
number of bins that I have.
And I can add that
as an argument here,
but if I specified the number
of bends equals 10 or 20,
whatever, then that's
the hard coating.
And I need it.
I need it to listen
to the input.
So finally, let's
open up this last one.
This is pretty
similar, but I've added
in to this kind of
more just for you
to play around with the time if
you want just a different way
of structuring it.
So you see, instead of
having just a sidebar layout,
I've kind of got that nested
within this tabs, that panel.
So it's just a different
way of organizing your app,
giving if you have
a lot of components.
I want to break these
across different pages
to make it a little
bit easier to navigate.
But the main thing that
we want to focus on
is here, where now
we have a histogram
and now we change
it to a scatterplot.
But instead of.
Just filtering, putting
in the entire data set,
we're filtering it into
this specific input
that we've created.
So that water input scroll up.
Right here, under this
radio button input,
we have an ID code,
water input, so any time
that radio button is
change, a different.
One is selected.
That's going to make
this function here
is listening for that change.
And when it changes, it's
going to rerun this bit of code
with that value of water input.
So if you're going for know
you're just playing around
with the data set and
you build up some plots,
you can often just stick
your coexisting code directly
into your server
function, you know,
wrap it and
renderPlot and usually
just need a change if you
want, or maybe sometimes
more inputs to
instead of, you know,
instead of doing
it by water input,
you have to prefix
it with input sine.
And you'll see over here
in our original code two,
there's the input.
Now instead of just
histogram, we're
showing the listening to
that the bean count graybeal.
Now, I can do this.
And it's doing what
we expect, yeah,
George ubinas, a lot of beans.
Now it's broken up
instead of having
another plot underneath
here, it's like, OK,
you want to look at
scatterplot and we
want to look at the scatter
plots of a number of houses
by death rate and
do this separately
for each water source.
Now, here, this is where I'm
selecting like New River now
selecting that water
input ID is changing
and this is really running.
So and then it's
outputting it to.
The object name scatterplot,
which we've selected here,
and that's the core
logic within China,
you have inputs that
have identifications
when those change the.
Server functions that listen
for them recognize that change,
recompute the visualization
based on that change.
And then output
it into the slots
that you've specified
these outputs
with the corresponding ID.
So that concludes this module
kind of building up the logic,
everything from this
point on is going
to be kind of playing around
with different ways of laying
things out, maybe a little
bit more complex apps
and more interactivity.
So check in here and see
if there are any questions.
Yeah, mike, let me
quickly take a look
and see what are some
things that we've got
that you can quickly discuss.
See?
yeah, here's one.
So do you have any
tips for naming ids?
They say they think this
becomes important for more
complex, shiny apps when there
are many identical widgets,
I.e., many text inputs.
Yeah, definitely, and
I think that's kind
of one of the areas that
can really snowball quickly,
especially if you are playing
around with the data set
and you make a
couple of quick shots
and you're like, oh, let me turn
this into a shiny, shiny app
and you create a
simple, shiny app like,
oh, that would be cool if it
did this and it would do this.
And then pretty soon
it can be pretty
easy to have some monster with
a bunch of different inputs
that are interacting
and really complex ways.
And again, that's why I just
kind of stepping back and have
it like once.
And that's totally
fine for interactive,
just building things
out, prototyping.
But at some point, you have
to step back and be like,
whoa, this is getting
more complicated.
Take a step back and refactor
it out, have a better layout,
try to identify,
you know, are you
how do you have
redundant inputs?
Can some be combined.
And then sit back and take a few
minutes, like make that sketch,
think about how the different
parts are interacting.
And then if you
really, truly do have
like identical code, like
maybe say we were just creating
like the same like histogram
over and over again,
but it was just
getting replicated
in a lot of essentially
the same code
was getting replicated
in a lot of different.
Parts, then?
The was earlier question
about shiny modules
that would be a
solution to that.
Cool Thank you.
And then I have I see one other
question coming in here, which
would be a good
one to discuss, is,
what are some good ways
for hosting shiny apps?
For example, can it
be hosted on github?
What are some
recommended services
that you would say
for hosting shinee?
Yeah, another great question
to cover this a little bit
in the wrap up, too, but
there's a few different options.
Ultimately, tiny apps
are just web apps
and they can be
run on any server.
So right now I'm just
running that locally
while it's on our Cloud.
But it's just using that Cloud
server as a local server.
You can do the same thing on our
studio, your desktop browser.
The obvious limitation is
that you can't share it
with anyone or to share.
You have to send your code.
They have to have
all the answers
to do all the right packages
installed, have to run it.
There's some easy
ways with shiny apps.
Then there's also within RStudio
enterprise suite of software.
There's RStudio Connect that
allows you to essentially,
I'm not I don't believe
I'm connected to a server
right now, but you can publish
a shining out just right
from RStudio.
And then if you have time
for one more question, cool,
I have a couple
more, but it's all.
However many questions you
want to take right now.
Another one is, how do you
parameterized shiny apps,
for example, if you wanted
to run the same report,
but for different segments,
is it easy to do this?
How would you do that?
That is a good question.
In some sense, Danny is kind
of taking care of the primaries
because it allows you to
select different values,
but say you wanted
the same plot.
And you are the
same, but you only
wanted it limited to
a particular year.
Particular data set,
particular time frame.
Actually, it might
bounce this to fail.
There Yeah, I'm here, I'm
here, I just I'm not sure
if I'm able to submit
through the chat box
as the person overseeing it.
So I sent a link to
Samantha, and there's
a couple of different ways
to dive into this question.
I think how I would
tackle it is integrating
R Markdown with shiny.
And so really what
you end up doing
is using R Markdown
as the report template
or the report engine
for your shiny m.
And so in the example
that I just sent,
Samantha, what it lets you
do is basically use the cat.
Oh, OK.
Is in the Jack.
Fantastic so basically,
you can use the option
and shiny there within
this application
that I'm shared
through the chat box
and it will let you
pick different variables
or different parts of
the data that you have.
And then what it will do is
dynamically and reactively
change the visualization.
And then for that
state, you can actually
use R Markdown in
the server folder
to x or excuse me, in
the shiny apps folder
to actually use R Markdown
to generate reports.
So this is a nice
example of how you
can use R Markdown is kind of
the behind the scenes report
engine and gives you that
capability of generating
reports directly
from your shiny app.
And is another reason
why in the workshops,
sometimes I'll really try hard
to make sure people understand
the connection between
R Markdown and shiny,
not only because you
can turn R Markdown
reports into shiny apps, but
because of this other way
to approach reports via shiny
apps and using R Markdown.
So yeah, so that's probably
how I would tackle it,
but there there's definitely
other ways to go about this.
And so.
Yeah, but but that one's pretty
simple in a nice, clean example
to work from.
Well, thanks, bill, and
yeah, and actually we'll
have an example on that,
that format of turning
R Markdown document,
embedding shiny into it
at the end of the workshop.
Yeah, yeah, Yeah.
I guess know, I think I
saw one other question
I can answer quickly about
using custom plotting code.
And the answer is yes, we're
using kind of building up
our own custom duty plot here.
If you wanted to use a base.
or a different.
An entirely different
library for visualisations,
you can put that
code in here, it's
just whatever output that
duty plot base are, ottley,
whatever it puts out
is going to get passed
through an appropriate render
function that will then
place that output in the
right spot of your app.
So absolutely.
You can create.
That's the idea behind that.
You can create your own
custom visualizations.
And, of course, make them
reactive and dynamic.
Cool, so I saw a few
more questions come in,
but mike, how are you
feeling about time?
Should we go ahead and maybe
take a five minute break?
Do you want to keep
on chugging through?
Do you want to do
some questions?
It's what do you feel
like doing right now?
All right.
Yeah, maybe now would be
a good time for a break,
and then, like I said,
we've kind of at this point,
we've covered the
core concepts and then
from now on, it's
just kind of making
it cooler layouts, more
complex interactivity,
that sort of thing.
Let's take five minutes.
Now Perfect we'll take
a five minute break
and then let's join again
at its 253 right now.
So let's go ahead and
join at 3 o'clock.
But we'll probably have
to be wrapping up probably
around three, 30
at the very latest.
Sub-group great.
Sounds good.
So with that, then I'm going
to hand it over to Kevin,
if Kevin, you want to just go
through and show that video
again, or maybe do any
overview on pricklier,
and we will give Mike a break.
Thanks, Samantha.
And I will go ahead and
share my screen again,
and I might actually, instead
of just playing the slide
silently, if there's
anybody who's
hanging around during the break,
I can walk us through slides.
So, again, Thanks to
everybody for sticking around
for this farmer excession
as part of the RStudio
global event, I hope
everybody's signed up
for different seminars
and presentations
throughout the global event.
It should be pretty
interesting, and I'm really
excited to see how
it's panned out.
And I hope when things
are back to normal,
we retain some sort of global
element to this conference,
because I think
it really provides
a really good opportunity to be
a bit more inclusive of people
around the world who can't
make it to the physical event.
But with that being
said, I just want
to give a quick talk through of
precognitive for anybody who's
still around.
And again, these slides were
flashing around earlier,
but just to reiterate
what Mike had
said at the start of
his presentation, how
we're entering data
solutions provider.
So, again, we mainly
concentrate on the data space.
So if it has nothing
to do with data,
that's where we're interested
in having an impact.
And so we started off
as a consulting firm
focusing on data science
and making an impact there.
But we quickly
realized that in order
to provide true value
to your customers,
you've got to really be
involved from the start.
And there's just
too many important
moving parts from the
start to the beginning.
So from that
advisory stage where
you're talking
about planning out
of what your architecture
is going to be,
a lot of companies moving
from on premise infrastructure
to on Cloud infrastructure or
maybe just moving from Excel
sheet to databases and whatever
stage of the data journey
they're at.
We like to meet with clients,
figure out where they're at
and where they
would like to go to
and help them architect
that solution.
And we've started to help
them, then actually setting up
that infrastructure to
our engineering practice.
And then where it gets
really interesting
and fun is where
a lot of things.
I think of the people
in this conference,
in RStudio conference and final
conference are interested in,
and that's around the
business, intelligence and data
science and analytics.
And that's where we
have a lot of people
who work for us and a lot of
knowledge in the open source
data science to that.
So a lot of R users
and our company,
python, and we like to
help our customers again,
insights through
dashboard development,
whether it be through
RStudio or other platforms
like powered by there as
well, is a very popular one
these days.
And yet, as Mike is walking
through here on the shiny apps
and a lot of our
organizations, especially
in the farm industry
of these shiny
and I can't blame them because
it's a fantastic to really
allows a lot of flexibility.
And it's maitua choice.
If if I had the choice
of which two of you.
It's the one I always tend
to gravitate towards that.
And of course, the more
data science, more advanced
analytics that
you can get to do,
where you set up some predictive
and prescriptive analytics,
where, you know, we're
not just telling you
where your data is going, but
we can help you figure out
what to change in order to
gain the kind of outcomes
that you desire inside of
your business operations.
Very popular, I think, in the
manufacturing setting is this
to get into machine automation
and stuff like that.
I think that's where
prescriptive analytics is
going to have a big impact.
And that obviously impacts
the farm industry with respect
to their manufacturing
processes, et cetera.
So, yeah, a lot of
really exciting things
going on, data, science,
analytics, and specifically
with prescriptive analytics.
And that starts to take hold.
I think we'll see some
really amazing innovations
in pharmaceuticals.
So just some of
the areas that you
can get in touch with
and using data science
machine learning to help
improve patient care,
help improve effectiveness
of drug trials,
become more targeted in
your sales, marketing
and, of course, accelerating
drug discovery and development,
which is a very popular use
case for artificial intelligence
in the fashion
industry right now,
using the likes of neural
networks, et cetera, to really
gain the power of data
science and high compute power
to come up with some really cool
innovations in the drug space.
This is just a quick overview
again of the general approach
that we like to take
a look at that's
similar to that first night I
showed that where we go end.
And so it's all about figuring
out where your business is
and where it wants to go to.
And after we've done
that, we've kind of
assessed what kind
of needs you have
to put in the plan
in place to move
your company towards a
more data driven approach.
And to our approach
and partnership.
We're able to drive some
actual insight there.
These are just a sample of
some of our previous clients,
existing clients and key
partners that we work with.
So RStudio being the main
one on showcase today,
we love working with those
guys and helping evangelize
for RStudio and team
suites, which we believe
is one of the most powerful
integrated environments
for analytics and data
science out there.
And we do a lot of work
hoping to apply that on Cloud.
So would it be obvious or.
Sure, jur?
We we think that this is the way
forward for RStudio deployments
and really helping lifescience
partners move to the Cloud.
Security is a big focus for us.
Full and it looks like
with that, we are exactly
at the top of the hour,
why don't we have it?
Go ahead and I'll
hand it over to mike,
who's going to take us
on our final sections
with shinee for the last 30
minutes of today's workshop.
So, mike, I'm going to
make you the presenter,
and it's great to have you back.
Oh, OK.
And my screen smoother
than last time,
it looks like it mastering
shiny screen right now.
Yes, exactly.
So I saw one question about
downloads and none of this
is built into the
material in the webinar.
But I just want to
quickly say that, yes,
you can upload and download.
And this is kind of a go to
reference book, mastering shiny
and essentially works by.
You know, there's a history
of it within your interface,
you specify download
buttons and links,
those get connected to actions.
So that when you click on
them, it triggers in this case.
Right, ESV, to a specific
location of your input data
set.
But you can also
do the same sort
of things like saving images.
So, yeah, check
that out if you're
interested in learning
more about that
and be connected here.
And go figure.
So actually show an
example of a different way
to say, if you just
wanted a different way,
that as a side effect has
allows you to download a plot,
there's kind of also
ties into the question
of why can you use
customized graphics?
You different packages.
Say you wanted to
let's just run this.
Those fancy app,
the first gapminder
are just run this app.
You just scroll through,
you can see that it's
quite a bit more complicated.
And we'll go through
that kind of section
by section here in a minute.
But it's a bit more
helpful, I think, just
to look and see what
it actually does.
And then when we get
to different sections,
you can tie it back to what's
happening in the running app.
So we've got a slider,
very seen that before.
In this case is
filtering on year.
So now we're now we're looking
at between year 1973 in 2011
and we're selecting a country.
So we're looking
at just marocco.
And in other
countries, it's showing
year versus life expectancy.
And we're also showing this is
we've only showed plots before.
Now we're showing a table.
And this is visualize using
the data table package,
which is actually
kind of a wrapper
to the an underlying JavaScript
library that if you don't get
you don't have to
think about it at all.
So the package.
And we're doing a bit more
complicated things for our set
as well, so we're using
this gapminder data.
Of course, gapminder has a lot
of countries other than these,
and we're also doing
so kind of collapsing.
Regions, so North America
doing some wrangling,
some preprocessing.
And and all of our
other apps, we've
kind of done everything
with it, there's
been it's like library shiny
big UI block, a big server
block, and then the
last line runs the app.
If you do need to do
some pre processing,
you can do in two ways.
You can use your
data set beforehand
and just call that
data sets ready to go.
But if you need to do
a little minimal pre
processing within the
app, you don't necessarily
want to include that
in the server function
because it might get called
more times than it needs
to be in that
results in your app
being a little bit slow
and less user friendly.
Sorry, I'll try not to do that.
I'm sure the behind the scenes
sure things are going OK.
So sorry about that.
Yeah, awesome.
Appreciate it, bill.
Yes, so here we're
doing some again,
if you don't know, plier,
don't worry about this,
but just think about this.
And we're just doing
some data wrangling.
We're specifying the countries
that we want to how it's West.
We're mutating and creating
this region group with the case
when statement SQL.
It's kind of analogous
to that, to that
if it's the regions
in West west,
if it's in these
countries, we're calling it
East Asia, et cetera.
Yeah dropping some
missing data, creating
a couple of new columns.
And we have a new data set to
work with called gapminder.
And then we switch
into our shiny stuff.
we've got our user interface
and then down here serologic.
Let's run this again
and get it going.
So, yeah, we got our input
and your input that's here.
And that's going
into this slider.
We've got to drop
that drop down.
We've seen those before selected
and put selected slider input.
And we've got our
main panel, which
we're calling the output cool.
You can call this
whatever you want to,
but obviously, if
you're building this up,
something more
complex, cool is not
going to be really descriptive
when you come back to your code
later or someone else
looks at your code
and tries to figure it out.
But any string.
There's going to be, you can
give it any name that you want.
This is new, so we
have our output.
We've got our plot output.
We've seen that before.
But the table that
we've got down here
needs a different
output showing he's not
going to know how to
process that as a plot
because it's not a plot
image. we give it you
know, we have this
function dt output.
And of course, finding
within the server,
we've got this chunk here,
it's called render plott
doing some filtering.
You know, we're not
redoing all of that data,
ranglin, that we did up above.
We're taking starting with the
output of that data Rangeley
and we're doing some
additional filtering.
So that's the filtering based
on where we put these sliders.
In this case, we got that input.
Your input.
You can see it's actually
now a list of length 2
the first element's going
to be that lower end point.
Second 12 is going to
be that upper endpoint.
And you're filtering
for years in between.
And then we're taking in
another country input here.
We're doing that filtering and
then we're creating our plot.
We're doing a similar sort
of thing for the output
and instead of render
plot, we're doing rendered.
So we're creating this new
data set called filter,
as is just a data frame.
And Where any time one
of these inputs changes,
it filters a data
set to just that.
And then renders
that in the slot
that we specified
for our table to be.
And then, of course, I
always need this at the end
to actually run your out.
I'm sure one thing
really quickly say
say you're familiar with
the plotline library.
And you want to turn this into
instead of a jackpot part,
you want to make this
interactive, turned this
into a polygraph,
you can actually
do that really easily
without, you know,
probably modifying just
three or four lines of code.
So we're going to call
the lottery library.
And when we go down here,
instead of plot output,
there's a whole plot layout put
out a couple of lines there.
Similarly with this, we've
got instead of render plot,
we need to do render plotless.
And then probably has
a function called.
Shortly that will convert a
plot object to a party object
and find the simplest way
to do this is actually just
to give you a plot to save
your plot as you'll give it
a name and then.
We can just now we have
that same plot, same guy
plot that we had before.
Now we're just going to
turn that into a plot.
We object.
I think we read load this.
Here we go.
Because, see, now
we've turned this
into a plotline object with
everything that comes with ways
we can hover over the points.
And I mention this
because if you
wanted to download a
copy of that quote,
we have that built in.
That's probably not the official
solution for upload download.
But if you just need
one plot downloaded,
that's also kind
of a hack for that.
And again, there was only
maybe four or five lines
of code to change,
to be change their.
Do we have.
I like to spend a little bit
of time on the last module,
and since it's kind of
going through all these
without kind of being able
to wander around and look
at everyone's
screens and help out,
I'm going to skip
over this exercise.
But because you
look at if you're.
Yeah want to.
Play around a little
bit more and kind of
see your understanding
this, if you go ahead
and run this as is, of
course, it's not going to run.
It's got a bunch of
kind of underscores.
It's placeholders.
So if you go through an.
There compared to the
previous one for certain bits,
and then this will build
up a more complicated map
with adding in some more
functionality and to go
through that.
And on your own time
if you're interested.
So finally going to move
on to flexdashboard.
And this is kind of taking a
step back a little bit know
we started out with R Markdown
that went into shiny apps.
And we have this structure with
the user interface and server
and inputs that are specified
in the user interface.
What those change
server logic is
watching, listening for that.
And then it reruns, whatever
code or visualization
that you've got
based on those inputs
and outputs it to your
final output in your app.
We're going to go back here.
And actually, this is just a
strict R Markdown document.
And this kind of gets
back to that question
that we had earlier
about parameter.
So this right here, we're going
back to our original data,
looking at adverse events.
This is exactly the same.
In fact, it's almost
exactly what we
we're going to recreate
that R Markdown down
in a flex dashboard format.
So there's a couple
of things here.
Output is specified.
Selex dashboard specifying the
or it's going be in columns,
specify that zeros
just depending on how
you want to organize your app.
This are code here
is all the same.
Your normal, R Markdown chunks.
Again, we've seen that before.
And OK, now we've
got some new stuff.
We've got columns with labeled
two headers, these dashes.
And then.
Within that, we've got
these level three headers,
the hashtag was finally, all
advanced age range events
by gender, and this
is specifying columns
within our dashboard.
And this is specifying
another column.
And we're going to put
two rows within that.
So building up this
grid sort of layout.
And if we run it or
actually R Markdown down,
we're going to Netlify.
Going back here, you
see, I didn't actually
put any code in here, this
isn't outputting any grass
or anything, so it's
all empty right now.
But we've got that first
column and then second column
with two rows in it.
And it's kind of this is instead
of having the user interface,
you're specifying the layout
within this flex dashboard.
Package, this structure
specifying columns and rows of.
That's kind of the basic
skeleton for setting it up.
What's go to adverse events.
And we got pretty
much the same thing
here, we've added a new
thing here, a parameter.
So this is parameter
as report on this case,
we're specifying it for aspirin.
Again, our code to get the data
and execute query at age range.
And now we've got that same
column, all events and column
with age range and events by
gender, the same structure.
But now we're going to.
Do a little, you know, put some
cloths in here and, you know.
Put a little bit of
information on what age,
we selected that sort of thing.
So it's.
Look at this moment to load.
So you can see the
parameter that we specify,
no drug aspirin is there.
We've got our age range in
that upper limit specified
use an icon in there.
We've got our two
plots, and that's great.
Kind of cool, clean
looking interface
as parameter presbyteries.
So say we want to go.
Back and run this.
Stay on Tylenol.
It's parameterize,
it's going to run
that give given a minute
there, but of course,
it's reproducibly easy to
regenerate for different drugs,
but it's still obviously
not as friendly
and not as interactive,
interactive like Kashyap is.
OK, so here we go.
Now we've got it for Tylenol.
So let's go to the last example
here, so adverse events,
shinee.
We're going to take that.
Previous dashboard that
we had and turn that
into an interactive one where
instead of having to specify,
you know, your drug
as a parameter, you
can just select it and
a quick scroll through.
It looks pretty
similar to what we
had before in terms of layout.
We've got these columns
of rows specified inside
and we've got all
of our, you know.
Joujou plots to build
up the visualisations,
get some more stuff
going on up here.
I can go through
all of it, but you
can see that we're
specifying a shiny runtime
is going to allow us to embed
shinee right in the dashboard.
This is all the
same, grab our data.
And now we've got this
first column, which
are formatting as a sidebar.
And so you can
see this is shiny.
It's the text.
We've seen slider input before.
Text input is allows us
to directly input text.
And this is our
input ID and that's
going to be our label and
the default value slider.
But you see, missing from
this entire thing is the UI
and again, flexdashboard.
And Shiny is taking care of
that for you in the background.
And you're just specifying
your inputs here.
You're creating a new
data set, and it's
wrapped in this
reactive statement,
and that reactive turns this
into from just regular code
to a reactive
object that listens
for changes in your input.
In this case, we're looking
at that slider and saying,
OK, we're going to whenever the
upper lower end point changes,
we're going to recreate
that that age label.
And then same thing
with male and female.
So then we have a male or
female for that particular age
range of drug.
And then going down here
instead of just Rg plot, like we
had in the last regular
Flex dash, for example,
we've got everything
wrapped in random plot.
And again, this isn't
within server logic.
And this is all taken care
of for you under the hood.
And you can just quickly take
whatever plot you've got.
You have you've
developed the prototyping
and have maybe had a
little bit of filtering
or wrap it and
renderPlot and you
can embed it right within
your inside your dashboard.
So let's run.
Documents and so this
looks kind of the right.
Part of this, ignoring that
left column looks exactly
like what we had before.
We got to age range our plots.
The main distribution bar
chart for adverse events,
but now say we want to go
back and look at aspirin.
Enter and get out.
I think we looked at truta.
Actually, there we go.
So now we've got that
interactive flexibility.
They've built up into
that dashboard structure
where they will quickly.
This is running as
a shiny document.
So the flex dashboard itself
is the regular dashboard
is an HTML that you can
send to someone else.
They can open it up
in their browser.
This does require a
server that's running are
and kind of one of the.
Solutions that we
briefly touched
on using shiny apps or RStudio
connect, posting it on your own
in some way.
So this does require a
server to be running shiny.
And looks like we've got
about 10 minutes left
before a hard stop, so let's
see if anyone has any questions.
I'll take a look and see
what we've got in the chat.
Here, I've got one.
So what is a good way
or a recommended way
to test shiny apps?
Do you use the
Shiny test package?
Oh, yeah, good question.
So on one, I guess
there's shiny UPS are made
of a whole bunch of things.
You've got the stuff
that's specific to shiny
and kind of how it's
all taxed together
in the reactive programming.
And of course, you
want to test, and then
you might as you build
up a more complex app,
you might also just
have regular functions
that you're importing.
And that doesn't do
a particular task.
And you want to make sure
that those are the same.
So then, of course, no
good programming practices
are important in developing and
documenting those functions.
And you.
We've already heard in
the session about things
like oxygen and tests
that to make sure
that you're documenting
and testing,
testing code that
you previously ritt,
you've previously written as you
update and make modifications,
the shiny test
package is also great.
We'll run a bunch of
tests on your own.
On your shiny map as
it all integrated,
so that instead of having
to, like spin it up,
have a bunch of people,
different people look at it.
And someone be like, oh,
like this drop down menu
doesn't update this
graph in the right way
or this isn't working.
Or you go here, and then there.
And then all of a
sudden, it breaks.
It does a lot of that
sort of testing for you.
So I think that's also
a good path for testing.
Great, Thank you.
And then I think we have enough
time for one more question,
and it looks like Carlos
answered it in the chat,
but I loved his answer.
So let me go ahead and
ask this question as well.
And Carlos, if you want to
jump on and answer as well,
you're welcome to.
But let's say you have a quite
expensive set of function.
Is it better to
interactively if when
each interaction is triggered
or put it externally
outside of everything?
I imagine a situation in which
you could have many of them.
So putting everything outside,
putting everyone outside
could be slowing
down the startup.
But the navigation will
be smooth as the opposite
of making the startup
quick, but slowing down
the usability in that situation.
What would be a good
strategy to refactor the.
Hi, can you guys hear me?
Yep, yeah, yeah, that is a
very interesting question,
and when I was touring
with I was thinking,
how would I do that.
So far for small
applications like the ones
that Mike has been
showing, I don't
think it would be
an issue of having
the functionality
of the app inside
of the application or outside
application as a practice.
I normally tend to build
the delivery processes
before the data
goes into the app,
and that is applied to any
other kind of visualization work
that you do like.
If you're using
Django and Javascript,
then you could do between
all of the preprocessing
on the database
of Django and then
you will be putting
the outputs directly
into a target's library
or something like that,
or the same with power Vi or
Tableau or all of these tools.
You would be using the
database to do the processing
and then those other tools would
be perceiving the clean data.
So for this question to
answer this question,
the application is too complex.
And I would recommend to use a
database to do all of that work
before the data goes out.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Thank you.
Thanks, Carlos.
Yeah, exactly, that's putting
it kind of as a general rule
of thumb, putting as little as
possible in the server logic,
because that's what it's going
to get triggered interactively
and then doing as much as
possible before you even
go into the app.
So, yeah, a
wrangling, processing,
modeling that can be done before
that can be done beforehand.
And then you just put in the
clean bill and clean data set.
That's a full speed
it up as well.
Yep, I just shared
a link with Samantha
about Joe James keynote at
the 2019 RCU conference,
where he talks a lot
about scaling shiny
and managing it and production.
And so it's a really good talk.
And it also talks
about the things
that Carlos just mentioned.
So so, yeah, yeah, well,
we're on that topic.
All time, so this as well,
you will see my screen here.
The resources slide.
Yes and then I also saw
the talk tanks talk YouTube
in the chat for everyone.
OK, awesome.
Yeah, like I briefly showed
this mastering shiny book, which
is a great intro and kind of
getting a broad overview here,
really going into those issues
of like trying to do stuff
at production grade
this book, I'm
actually not sure if that's
been fully released yet.
Might still be a
work in progress
is also a really good source
for those sorts of problems.
Wonderful Thank you so much,
mike, and Thank you to everyone
here.
Let me quickly wrap
this up for everyone.
So thank you again to everyone
that has joined us today
for the R RStudio global are
in farma excession brought
to by prokaryote.
If you haven't registered
for RStudio global, which
I hope most of you have, go
ahead and do that now are 24 R
marathon of events kicks
off on Thursday for everyone
that did join us today.
Materials will be available
on materials and videos
for sessions that we can
share will be made available
for you via email and
online following RStudio
global conference.
I've saved most of
the questions here.
So if there's any that we
are able to follow up on,
we can do that through
RStudio Community.
And once again, Thank you to
all of our wonderful presenters
today for sharing all of
their industry expertise.
Thank you, everyone, and
we'll see you at global.